so I was chatting with Howard Henan
ideas for a talk like this and he
suggested the name moving faster so
thank you Howard he also told me a story
his wife Teresa can type 90 words a
minute which I gather is kind of par for
the course for a professional typist it
sounds scary to me but and thirty years
ago her computer could keep up with her
so let's look at that a minute 90 words
minutes four hundred and fifty
characters per minute right seven and a
half characters a second so thirty years
ago I had a Mac two on my desk had one
thread running at 16 megahertz so let's
see that's per character two million
instructions right per character of
course it could keep up you can do a lot
in two million instructions so we got
frozen for 30 years and they've just
thought us out and now it's 2018 well I
just bought this thing a couple of weeks
or a couple of months ago and it's a
yeah it's that it's got eight threads
running at two gigahertz when it's calm
it goes faster than that so what's that
everybody two billion instructions per
character so you all know where this is
going right Howard's wife Theresa her
computer today doesn't keep up with her
typing
what are we doing wrong
I mean that's ridiculous
well I don't know all the answers but
here's some things that I think that we
might be doing wrong and I'm going to
talk about some specific things that
maybe we can do better so when does
efficiency matter typing really
seriously the world record for typing
speed according to Wikipedia is 216
words per minute set by this person in
1946 on an IBM electric typewriter that
was pre ball not a Selectric okay
computer can't do that I mean and over
the last thirty years a thousand times
increase in speed I mean sure we're
doing more but are we doing a thousand
times more stuff well there's a lot of
you know there's a lot of reasons for
this and I'm only going to talk about
some of them but I want to give you a
couple of examples though of when
efficiency matters company I used to
work for they hired me to work on a
program that extracted data from their
database and made a product with us is a
digital map company so their data was
pretty big and their system took three
weeks to run and that one of the things
they wanted me to do is make some
intermediate stopping points so that you
know if something went wrong they didn't
have to go back all the way to the
beginning of the process well I didn't
do that I rewrote it to run and five
maybe it was eight something like that
anyway overnight about a hundred times
increase I mean this was a game changer
business why
as you can well imagine the current
company I work for we have a test
automation system for our rail simulator
and 2,700 tests we have at the moment
take about an hour and ten minutes to
run today we're rewriting it different
design reducing that to about twenty
seconds so that's also going to be a
game changer for test-driven development
so my point here is that efficiency
matters efficiency always matters this
kind of efficiency is something that you
can get I mean this kind of efficiency
change is something that you're going to
get with design changes which is not
what I'm here to talk about today but
once you've made those big design
changes now all of a sudden your code is
running much faster and now the
bottleneck may be things that aren't so
obvious subtler things in the
implementation and that's what this talk
is about so where does efficiency matter
the rule of thumb that I grew up with
was don't optimize your code right at
the nice clean way go find the five
percent of the code that's spending
ninety five percent of the time and fix
that well you may throw things at me but
I don't think that's the whole story
I think that's necessary but not
sufficient and I think that there are
many programs that do not spend all
their time in a small big small bit of
code and that if you write a big huge
program without thinking about the
performance anywhere you'll end up with
a big huge slow program that you can't
really fix actually the rail simulator
is an example of this because if you run
it electrically with the electrical
traction power simulation on it actually
does spend almost all of its time in a
very small bit of code
but if you run it with the electrical
simulator off it actually spends its
time all over the place and there's no
one spot that you can fix so I say right
almost everything optimally but optimize
code is ugly right I think in C++
optimal code can be elegant and that in
fact optimal code is typically the most
correct code and so therefore kind of by
definition the most elegant code I think
that our idioms should be for optimal
code and our idioms are the kind of by
definition the elegant way to do things
and if something really ends up being
ugly you can hide it in C++ behind a
very elegant zero overhead abstraction
often this is done in a standard library
in fact the date-time library does this
all over the place
matrix arithmetic libraries do this so
what about compilers well compilers
today are very smart and they can't fix
design problems that's pretty obvious
but they also can't get around all
coding in efficiencies they'll fix that
right don't have to worry about that but
they won't fix this and we're going to
go into this and what's wrong with it
so I grew up with simple architectures I
didn't know what a cash was
floating-point was super expensive this
was back in the the old days all right
the golden rule used to be reduce FP
divides count your FP divides and get
those down as far as possible if you
wanted your code to go fast
well floating points faster than integer
now or certainly as fast I didn't
actually realize that until not that
long ago when I suddenly did some
experiments and realized wow you know
this this rule that I've been holding in
my mind it's just not true
so caches caches are big and they're
much faster than main memory but they're
not big compared to main memory and this
faster they get the smaller they get
there's more than one right so locality
of reference is critical which means
that size matters the fact that you've
got 32 gear 16 32 gigabytes of RAM
doesn't mean you can just arbitrarily
write huge code because it won't perform
because of caches so cache misses cache
misses are the new floating-point
divides so theorem 1 avoid cache misses
dynamic allocation heap allocations are
the most expensive things we do I mean
we're not talking about going out on the
internet for something and deallocations
are the second most expensive so we need
to reduce these as much as possible we
need to count our allocations don't
worry about counting floating point
count our allocations reduce them
ideally to zero can't always do that
standard containers they use heap
allocation but heap allocations are not
only expensive but the locality of
reference is terrible they're all over
the place right so there's a double
whammy
so theorem number to avoid allocations
the stack on the other hand is
contiguous so it does great locality of
reference and it's used constantly so
it's always in cash so if something
isn't too big and its local should be on
the stack a reason to put it in heat
nothing's faster than a register right
and there so the the compilers gonna try
and put things into registers there's
lots of them
it's gonna use them in fact lots of
variables are only in a register ever
but if you take the address of a
variable or of course if it's involves
dynamic allocation it's not going to be
only in a register all right so that and
by the way I didn't mention but
interrupt with questions any time so
those are some basic principles maybe
most of you already know these things
let's talk a little bit about embedding
objects so size matters and locality of
reference matters and dynamic
allocations matter so you've got a
contact object do you implement the
phone numbers as a vector or as an array
well it's a trade off right if you do it
as a vector you're gonna end up with two
different allocations and bad locality
of reference if you do it as an array
well you've got a limited size and array
doesn't actually have a size so you're
gonna have to have some way of putting
phone numbers into it and telling that
the rest of them aren't valid so this is
your situation but this lower approach
has a potential to run an awful lot
faster
we don't today have a fixed capacity
vector or a short string optimization
what I call it SSO it's probably really
a short buffer optimization vector both
of these are ideas that are being
floated for the standard library but we
don't have them today this would be a
perfect case for the short string
optimization right because you usually
just have one or two phone numbers and
sometimes you've got ten well we can go
better right embedding objects what
about if we embed on job jex on top of
each other how can we share space well
unions in C++ 98 unions were kind of
useless you can't really put anything in
a union that means much of anything
that's got fixed in C++ 11 so you can
use unions they're quite useful they're
still dangerous if you write one thing
and read another you're doing an
undefined behavior don't do that but you
can really save space and that saves
time but unions aren't really ever safe
so also in C++ 17 we have variants the
variant is a safe Union and they're
great should certainly use them but they
add some extra space because they have
the the type tag so you can't for
example save 4 bytes when you want to
superimpose two intz by using a variant
whereas you can do that with the Union
before I go on another thing I don't
have a slide for but it's quite
important be sure and squeeze all the
air out of your objects - meaning order
them by size so that the compiler
doesn't put in a bunch of padding bytes
we saw really this morning's talk by
Arthur was had a great example of that
where he had this tremendous speed
increase because he just got something a
little bit smaller and it ended up
fitting in the cash so now I'm going to
talk about passing things around because
I mean one of the reasons I wanted to do
this talk was that I'm always asking
myself um you know how do I pass this
how do I pack get this back from a
function what's gonna be most efficient
I wasn't sure the answers so here's some
of the answers past simple things by
value value semantics are a good thing
anyway and C++ has all kinds of great
support for value semantics but remember
that you're making a copy and sometimes
a copy is expensive if you need a copy
anyway then cost nothing pass by value
generally speaking we pass other things
by Const reference even shared pointer
so Neko had a great talk here forget
what year it was three years ago maybe
where he pointed out that passing shared
pointer by reference when all you want
to do is read it is a lot faster than
passing it by value which is kind of a
natural thing to do so pass by constant
reference also if you're writing generic
code and you want to know okay what
should i what how should I take this
parameter take it by constants it
doesn't matter if it's a built-in type
it'll be just as fast I measured this
it's just as fast there's no penalty if
you're passing an int and you're taking
it by conference not a problem but of
course you know all the usual caveats
where the reference you have to be
concerned about lifetime and what and
there's some efficiency considerations
so watch Nico's presentation
now I know that your mother told you not
to speak to strangers and not to pass
things by Const reference by non
conference it makes code much harder to
understand reason about depending on
what it is that you're sending in value
semantics may be just fine
move gives us a huge benefit depending
on what your objects like but sometimes
it's necessary and sometimes it's much
more efficient so I'm going to give you
an example of when it's much more
efficient so here all I want to do is
with this one vector I'm gonna go
through a loop some number of times and
every time I'm going to clear it I'm
gonna load some stuff into it and down
here I didn't write any code I'm gonna
do something with it and I'm gonna come
back and do it again
lots of times okay so let's think about
what happens the second time through the
first time through you know the vector
I'm passing it by value here write the
first first time through it's empty
nothing really happens a bunch of
allocations happen here as it fills it
up it gets returned right it gets
returned by value which means and we're
going to talk about this in a little bit
but it means that it's going to have the
rvo so there won't be any particular
cost to that all good right what happens
the second time through the second time
through what happens here thoughts
questions anyone let's look the second
time through the key size is a thousand
right and capacity on this thing or
whatever I did it on happens to be 1066
the library was using so we do a clear
the size of zero the capacity is 1066
right we do it we call load numbers we
do a copy constructor
right now it happens size is zero right
we didn't move anything there aren't
anything out there but the capacity is
zero right because I've constructed a
new one with an empty one I'm not going
to get that capacity right it's not
going to do any allocation system until
I actually do something with it and I
have my whatever 10 allocations again
every time through the loop I'm gonna do
all those allocations this is gonna go
super slow so let's pass it by Universal
ref that's not the right word anymore
it's forwarding reference right yeah
yeah yeah yeah right right exactly
I get those confused so we're gonna move
it here right we're gonna take simple
our value reference so what happens so
this fixes it right
sure no problem we we move it here and
there's no constructor at all happening
here right we got our capacity we fill
it up zero allocations all good is there
a problem here anyone notice anything
that's true but it's worse than that
what's this number is not the same what
happened to our 1066 now it's a thousand
that's because it got returned by a copy
constructor which is kind of what you're
saying but not only did we knock at the
our vo we did not get automatic move
here so we're copying it every time
still pretty slow not as slow but still
pretty slow
so what can we do about this well we
have to do the move explicitly and now
we have no rvo we have two moves here
and here but we have zero allocations
and zero copies so we're doing pretty
good can we do better that's pretty good
I mean notice we got our capacity back
where it should be what happens if we
pass it by good old-fashioned
non-contrast well thoughts well when we
pass it nothing happens the size is what
it is the capacity is what it is no
allocations occur when we return nothing
happens because there is no return no
return statement all right
this is fully optimal we're not paying
for moves we're not paying for anything
so it doesn't get better than this
so for situations like this passing by
non contra it's a good thing even though
your mother said not to myself I'd pass
bike by non construct before pointer but
that's I mean that eliminates certain
yeah same same it does the same thing
all right so how do we return so return
by value unless you're writing an
accessor you're gonna get copy elision
return value optimization in many
circumstances everyone I'm assuming
everyone knows what that is but just
briefly it means that there's nothing
happens at all because the object that
you're actually working on in the
function is the object at the call site
and this is man day
actually mandated in C++ 17 I believe
under certain circumstances if copy
elision does not occur then an automatic
move may occur basically what happens is
the compiler tries returning the
expression as an r-value and if it can't
it returns it as an l-value but an R via
and r vo is better than a move because
of the r vo nothing happens the move
actually has to do the move so there's
some rules here
don't do don't do a move in your return
statement you notice I had to do that
before to get it to do it but if you do
you will inhibit the copy elision so
don't do it
if you don't have to the function return
types got to be exactly the same type as
the type you're returning or it can be a
local variable excuse excuse me or a but
a vie by value parameter if you have
multiple return statements that will
often inhibit the r vo I gather that's
because it's hard to implement so it's
gonna depend on your compiler i don't
know that data of what compiler does
what here but multiple return statements
will not stop the automatic move from
happening conditional expressions on the
other hand will often prevent the
automatic move so either do one of these
okay don't do this without the moves
so here's some examples of good return
statements all of these are going to be
are gonna be fine and here's some
examples of bad return statements these
all have the potential to inhibit your
efficiency questions I'm going fast so I
with it
hoping not to run out of time too badly
the third one now no I know it's doomed
you yeah I mean you could do an explicit
move no you can't you can't you can't
you're doomed yeah yeah
maybe really what you wanted to do is
pass by non-contract I'm assuming
everyone knows quite a lot about moving
so I'm not going to belabor moving right
anyone want me to spend time on move the
the main issue is coming up move
semantics solves a whole lot of problems
and makes a lot of code go a lot faster
because you're not actually copying
stuff around that you don't need to be
works very well however there's lots of
objects that absolutely move semantics
do nothing for and it's very easy I've
found to say oh well it'll be fine
because because we've got move well
it'll only be fine because of move if
your objects manage resources but if
your objects just contain resources
which is what you want them to do in
general as we talked about earlier you
want to embed things in your objects to
make them smaller and to and to limit
allocations
well those objects are not going to get
no benefit from moving at all the
contact object that we talked about
moving and copying the same thing okay a
standard string is the same thing if it
contains 15 characters or less from in
most most libraries right because the
standard string has a short string
optimization which is great and the cost
of copying the string when it's 15
characters is the same as the cost of
doing a move okay I measured this it's
the same cost but it's still a cost and
if you're doing a whole lot of them that
cost might matter
I threw this in here mostly to get you
to watch Howard's discussion of move
oops sorry wrong button in fact if you
take away nothing from this talk but the
resolution to go watch Howard's talk and
Nico's talk fine they're great the big
thing here is you often don't need to
write any of these because they get
written for you and they're often
correct all right let's look at an
interesting case of doing a move so
what's happening here this good bad and
different anyone boy is everyone asleep
what's going on here is that you're
getting a copy
that's what push back does push back
takes a const con stress and it was
going to do a copy of this string and
let's say this is your latest russian
novel that just happens to begin with
hello world
you're gonna copy all of that so that's
not so good so let's fix it does this
fix it sure right in place is great
right that fixes it does this fix it
this is exactly the same code in fact if
you step in to the to the library that I
use you'll find that pushback calls in
place back ok so why doesn't this fix it
well because in place backs just calling
that same constructor what about this
does this fix it hmm question yes no yes
what's that I think as well as it can
for this code now we're going to get a
move
of course down here if you look at s
you're going to be in trouble right so
this isn't necessarily ideal but you
know this is pretty good we've gotten
rid of the copy we aren't copying your
Russian novel anymore ok what about this
situation though we've you've decided
that instead you're you're writing a
very short poem well does this help
no we just discussed that right it's a
short string optimization it's not going
to go any slower than the code we just
saw even though the code we just saw how
to rush a novel hanging off it but it's
not going to go any faster that's true
oh you're saying you're saying that it's
going to write a null right so so it
might be slightly slower okay
so what do we do does L know the same
thing okay how can I thought we could
use in place to fix this somehow
can we why yes
like this this is how in place is meant
to be used okay
we're going to construct the thing in
the string in place in the first place
with our initial piece and then we're
going to act on that particular string
and there's no other string involved
I'll stir that requires 17 only be cut
but only because of this here you can do
this and it you can do the same thing
it'll work just as well it's just one
more line of code because you can't in
place back prior to 17 did not return
anything and so you would have another
line that says Auto reference s equals V
dot back but that won't cost you
anything
thank you for pointing that out okay
questions
how about this situation well we're just
okay no we're in the same we're back in
a similar situation here because we now
have to construct an R value right which
can be moved from for sure and will be
but the move is going to cost you
something maybe more than you think this
does absolutely nothing because they
were already our values move is just to
cast our value this however does exactly
what you want okay
I have to take a little sidebar to talk
about perfect actually it's more than a
little sidebar now isn't it yes I'm
going to talk about perfect forwarding a
little bit this is a little bit
different but it still leads into a
discussion of efficiency in case you
aren't sure because it took me a long
time to be sure in fact I think it was
sometime last Tuesday what standard
forward actually does it's used only in
generic contexts and it ensures that you
retain the r-value Nisour l valueless
whatever you're passing down into
another function and you need to use a
this is now the correct use of the term
forwarding reference for this so I want
to look at a little case study of you
actually using this so I've got this foo
which I construct with some stuff okay
and I want to call call it with this so
what's the problem here
we just discussed this at length right
what happens here in efficiency right
same inefficiency we've just talked
about so what can we do to fix this well
it's actually pretty easy you make this
a template you make this a forwarding
reference
you call forward and pass that on to
your string and now this is fully
efficient this directly constructs the
string in place and all as well now
let's look at a slightly more
interesting situation supposing I have
this class bar and I want bar to have a
vector of foods so how should I write
that what's the best way to write that
ad I want to I want an ad because I
don't want to expose this to the public
but I do the public knows that I like
hold foods so the public wants to stick
Foos in so this is my first attempt well
this is terrible for the construction of
the foo is good we just fixed that but
now I'm gonna copy the foo right
entirely including the string I'm not
going to get moved to happen here and
the call sites really ugly so my first
thought is okay I can fix the call site
by just doing this I'll pass in the you
know what I want and then I'll push back
and I'll put the foo here well that's
nice it cleans up the call site but it's
no more efficient it's doing exactly the
same thing so I know I'll use modern C++
this help no this does exactly the same
thing
is it no I don't think so oh yeah right
that the thing is that right the thing
is that food doesn't doesn't implement
move string implements move but food
doesn't that's true
so you would get that is true you are
getting the free move good good point so
if we move of a short string which isn't
free good point yes this one oh yeah so
this is something I do I don't know I
should but I do it for very simple I
almost always named my member variables
with an M underscore so I can tell their
members unless it's a really simple
struct where it's it just seems
pointless like my point doesn't say M
underscore X M underscore Y it just says
X Y and when I do that I actually do
this because yes you can it's totally
legal and in my way of thinking it's not
we wanted something this simple it's not
confusing but I could one could argue
that easily the other way that's true
that is true
there's another problem with this by the
way there's a subtle
correctness problem here what's that
someone here surely can come up with
this that's right the correctness
problem is that we haven't constrained
STR at all and that's easy to do well
it's kind of easy to do today not that
easy but in this company pretty easy
it's gonna be way easier to do it C++ 20
when we can use it requires but I'm just
pointing that out it's not germane to
our conversation but it is true all
right so some good good points here so
we do get the free move but it's not
really I mean remember the string isn't
the whole story here we're moving some
other stuff here and these don't have
move semantics okay this is just bike
copying so what do we do
does this help
assuming a pointer to character well we
know that it stores it as a stood string
but well that's true regardless of what
food does exactly this only accepts
string literals suddenly I broke Mike
what's that that's right or other it
only accepts char star it does not
accept strings so I just broke half my
code so what do we really want to do
well turns out it's the same oh we want
to do this well no that gets us right
back to the same situation in fact what
we want to do is this
now this suffers from the same
correctness thing we just talked about
but that aside this is really awesome
because now not only is this optimal
from a runtime point of view because we
are calling the constructor directly
with this of foo directly with this in
place but now when foo changes that gets
some some more constructors adds some
more parameters got some default
parameters doesn't matter bar doesn't
change it just works questions
yes I think the question is if if we
change this from a queue to an R does
that make another ad get get
instantiated the answer's no because the
type of quote our quote and the type of
quote queue quote are the same and this
is a this is a type parameter that's
correct that's correct that's right
because they're different lengths and
that is that is true if you were going
to call this a bunch with a bunch of
different ones of these you may want to
do something about that but if you don't
I mean if it's if it's if you don't
really have that many literals I mean
how many different length literals are
you gonna have right before it starts to
be some other way you're doing it a
single parameter of what type Oh be
because I'm passing in four things what
because it and we don't want to
construct a food down yeah question okay
now different topic there's a reason why
we have all of these different
containers and why we'd like some more
they all have a purpose and they all
have different trade-offs between these
three things speed space and convenience
but it's really really important to pick
the right container for the job and
we're gonna look at that in some detail
so the first question that really comes
up is when should I use vector right
actually I'm gonna claim that that's the
wrong question I think this is the
better question when shouldn't I use
vector it's the go-to container the
other containers can have vastly better
performance or the other sometimes
vector won't work at all we're going to
talk about that or vastly greater
convenience and maybe performance just
really doesn't matter there are those
situations but start by analyzing
weather vectors the right thing to use
so vector why is it great contiguous
memory fastest traversal random access
right all of these things because it has
contiguous memory on the other hand
growth and validates everything if it
grows but you don't have to have a
vector grow you can pre reserved if you
know if you either know how many things
you have or you know how what is a
number that's larger than how many
things you're gonna have you can pre
reserved and you won't get any thrashing
and you won't get any movement so now
all your references and iterators will
not get they are never going to get
invalidating
if you're trying to do large amounts of
data you cannot use a vector because it
grows geometrically if you've got four
gigabytes of RAM and you've got a two
gigabyte vector that's full and you want
to add one integer to it you cannot do
that so vector doesn't work for large
things array array is great it's just
like a C array only a cleaner fancier
it's great when you want to embed
something in your object so how do I
choose well if the size isn't fixed you
kind of need to use vector B really nice
if we had a vector that has a fixed
capacity but we don't yet I personally
use C arrays for very simple situations
you following the principle that use the
simplest tool for the job and that's and
that's a very good point I mean that's
that's a good argument against what I'm
saying
and I you know I go back and forth on
this I tend to use you know if I have
three thing if I have three numbers that
I need access to you know in the
function this you know half a page long
I generally use a see array but as soon
as you start trucking in it you know
around your program then that argument
really starts to cut in I'm sorry
good point thank you the question was or
that the comment was why that that CRA
has pointer decay characteristics that
are surprising and annoying and that if
you use standard array you don't get
that
so Dec is great I really like deck
because deck has clumps of contiguous
memory and that gives you pretty fast
traversal and you get random access
growth invalidates only iterators not
your pointers and references but it has
linear growth so you can use it for
large amounts of data on the other hand
if you have a small amount of data decks
are very wasteful and they were slower
and lard much larger so simple rules
right the thing is pushing the whole
point of deck is you can push to the
front it's faster to push to the front
of a vector until your vector gets
pretty large so other other factors are
more important the question was what
what do I mean by small and large that's
coming yes almost not quite list
what are lists for their node based so
the overhead is very high the locality
of reference is terrible right because
you have to allocate a separate node for
every single element and they're all
over the place it gets slow or certainly
slower traversal you get no random
access on the other hand they're
perfectly stable growth that growth
anywhere never invalidates anything and
they have perfectly linear growth like
per element so you can make them very
large on the other hand they use up an
awful lot of space per element so you
know unless your if your element is very
large and then the overhead of the list
ism
unimportant but if your element is an
INT the overhead of the list is quite
important if they're if you have a small
one there's almost no good argument for
them so vector is much much smaller and
much faster for anything up to I mean
insertion anywhere in a vector is much
faster until you get pretty large and
we're going to talk about that in a
minute the big read a big reason to use
lists is when you can benefit from
splicing
so let's look at some numbers what I did
here this this fine print basically says
this is for when you read the slides
later is that I created 10 million I had
I had a table of 10 million things I
used a map that's not involved in the
discussion my thingies had a list I'm
gonna call it a list I don't mean it had
a kind of container that contains some
elements and I implemented that three
ways list deck and vector when the
container size for each of my elements
of the larger thing was 10 and I had 10
million of them look at the times this
is the time spent just what I did was I
pushed that happen to see it yeah I
pushed them into the front of the list
and then I removed them from the front
of the list okay
so worst case for four-vector and look
at the numbers I mean vector blew
everybody away
I mean incrementally so over deck but
way faster than the list and look at
this memory used by all this okay
so list is just way better there's no no
no argument I mean excuse me vectors way
better no argument I went up to a
hundred ok deck has pulled ahead speed
wise but I mean look at the memory usage
so okay it's a little faster to use a
deck but do I really want to expend that
much more memory depends on your
situation list is still way behind now
when I make the interior container a
thousand well I didn't use list at all
because that just ran too slowly to
measure in this situation
because I had 100k of them and I wanted
to keep the numbers in the same ballpark
deck is now you know really really fast
and vectors now quite a lot slower but
it's still a lot smaller questions set
and map so this slide should look
familiar
it's the same slide as for lists the
same principles apply your nodes
it's a node based container it's just a
matter of how you hook them up so
arbitrary insertion is faster until the
size is quite large this shouldn't be
surprising at this point maintaining
order is faster until the size is quite
large if you need to maintain order
binary search on vector works just as
well as searching in a tree in fact it's
probably faster for small containers
linear search is faster than binary
search you don't need to keep it in
order if all you're doing is gonna find
it it's actually faster to do a linear
search so let's look at how I tested
this so I created an element that was
going to keep a set of integers
conceptually so I a unique ordered list
of integers and I said okay that's what
I need in this thing and I threw in
something else just to make it somewhat
realistic and I implemented this two
ways this is one way this is the other
way they work identically the only
difference is that this uses a vector
and I wrote this probably fairly dumb
insert that just does a ordered insert
okay and then I ran the comparison so
again at ten million objects of size ten
vectors faster and way smaller now mind
you what it says here in the fine print
is that I put the elements in backwards
so that there was worse case for vector
again the vector had to slide I put him
in and then I put him in again and it
and in the first case the vector had to
slide every time it never got the
advantage of oh it goes in the end it
had to actually make room every time so
worst case for vector at a hundred well
vectors even fit I mean there's you know
tenth as many of them but vector is the
the improvement of vector over said is
more at size a hundred I would have
thought that you know it would get worse
and worse no it's actually more so at
size 100 and far more savings in once we
get to a thousand vectors now behind set
in terms of time but I mean look at the
memory usage and it's not way behind
right it's just incrementally slower
does this all make sense questions it's
not as bad right I wanted to make it
worst for vector yeah that's a good
point
so theorem three right is vector except
of course when it's not the right choice
my real point is you have to make this
choice every time sure okay so
interesting so okay so the comment was
that under some circumstances with a
good hash function an unordered map hash
map of some sort but presumably mean the
standard one yeah and if you don't care
about order is even better than vector
I'd be interested to see if that's true
as the size gets small because the
overhead of that is going to be
tremendous for small containers right I
mean I didn't include the unordered maps
and I probably should have because it
they're definitely different but I think
that this gets the point across which is
for every use you need to evaluate which
is the correct container for this
situation not not you noted every other
situation is different
right see if I can paraphrase that
you're saying be sure and benchmark
exactly what you're doing the set of
operations yeah that because it's
something different is going to behave
differently yeah okay
so now we come to the spiritual portion
of the talk we're going to have a little
eastern philosophy here and we're going
to talk about how you can move even
faster by not moving at all so we've
already seen that objects may not get
any benefit from being moved right what
moving is just as expensive as copying
furthermore construction and destruction
may have side effects that you don't
want to repeat if your object launches a
rocket in its constructor and blows it
up in its destructor you probably don't
want an accidental copy in there that
might not go well and that can be true
of things that are less dramatic right
like a database connection and you may
want objects to be stable in fact some
objects want to be permanently stable
for their entire lifetime
okay node-based containers are stable
vectors can be used in a stable way but
you need to get things into them and out
of them okay and sometimes esoteric
examples aren't necessary sometimes you
have a simple little object it's got 128
bytes it's your you know your contact
object it's got a couple of phone
numbers and you whatever but you've got
zillions of them so it's just too
expensive to mess around constructing
destructing copying etc etc so and we've
this is this is somewhat repeating
things that I've already said but
basically you want to use in place to
construct things in place so that they
never have to move or copy okay
here's some reasons why you'd use in
place this is one of my favorite little
idioms okay and yes you can do this and
C++ 14 and earlier by just with two
lines of code but I really like it now
I've got my vector let's say I call him
place back i I'm asking for the default
constructor because I don't want it to
have anything because I'm about to read
it from a file I just call read I pass
it the file object boom I've just read
element number one when not to use it
the question was that the default
constructor might also be expensive sure
but it's hard to imagine how you would
well yeah absolutely so so there's a
reason I use this but you you also
another idiom that would solve that
problem is to have a this is assuming
that there isn't a constructor a read
constructor on the object but if there's
a read constructor on the object you
just take this read and a couple of
parentheses out and you call them place
back with the file object and you've
eliminated that problem good question
when not to use in place well if it's a
copy anyway like for built-in types
principle of using the simplest tool for
the job is says use push back not in
place there's another little more subtle
one if you want to ensure that explicit
constructors are not called if you call
push back you will ensure that if you
call someplace back it will call
explicit instructors because that's what
you're doing is calling the constructors
of the object Alistair
okay you have to know more about okay so
they yeah so allister's comment was that
you could argue the simplest tool for
the job the other way and say that it's
simpler to call in place back because
then that's what you always use and you
don't have to think about well should I
be calling push back or in place back
how simple is simple you just always use
that and it's not as we've seen it's not
gonna matter at runtime because it's
gonna call them place back anyway so the
question the comment was that with
aggregate construction you mean with
braces yeah with aggregate yeah with
aggregate construction
you can't call in place back I don't
know about that is that true does anyone
else I mean you and Wyatt why is that I
think
yeah okay that's that's interesting so
aggregate the comment was that aggregate
types require a curly brace initializer
and that that gets lost in the process
of passing it down through in place back
to the constructor right yeah he said
there's an it's a non deduced context
right
okay so Alistair says that that it's
maybe going to get fixed for 20 and the
other thing was that it works now in
certain special cases right okay okay
interesting I don't do much with other
than to just use them I don't do much
with aggregate initialization myself all
right so now let's talk about splicing
here's another way of not moving or
copying out things stay put everyone
knows that splicing is right let's have
a splice method in fact it's one of the
few reasons to use lists is that you can
splice it nothing's invalidated it's
super fast you're just twiddling
pointers all right we all know this
right you go from here to here okay
until c++ 17 there's nothing you
couldn't do anything like this to a map
or a set alright and furthermore you
couldn't change the key of an element
anything like that that you wanted to do
you had to create new elements delete
old elements construction copying all
this stuff we're trying to avoid with C+
17 we have node extraction with node
extraction you can do all these things
and more you can change the key of an
element you can transfer elements around
even between maps and multi maps you can
merge one container into the other you
can take an element out and hold it for
later use I'm going to show an
interesting example of this and you can
move an element out of a set I actually
didn't realize this until very recently
but until node extraction you could put
move only elements into a set and then
presumably observe them there but you
couldn't move them out of the set which
seems like a major problem so let's look
at how node extraction works let's say
you want to change the key of an element
and all the other things sort of follow
the same pattern so let's say we want to
change this guy from X to Y well what we
do is we remove it from we extract it
from the map or set from the container
and we hold onto it with a node handle
then we can change the value because
it's no longer a member of the container
you see it's not the same color anymore
so we can we can change the key without
messing up the container the containers
happy it doesn't have that element
anymore and now we can put it back in
you'll notice the element never moved
memory all we did was twiddle the
pointers and change the the key value so
what's the code looked like for this
well it's awfully simple here's my map
all right I call extract pass it a value
or or a an iterator and I get this node
handle thing which we have to use Auto
for because it's a one of these you know
secret library types it's not secret
it's in the standard but it's nothing
that you really want to mess with but
you do want to use its API - whoops
sorry to access the key it gives you a
non Const or the key don't inquire too
hard as to how that happens and then you
just call insert now this node handle
thing is a move only type right for good
reason you wouldn't want to make a copy
of it that's the whole point is that
you're trying to move this thing and not
copy it not I mean you're trying to
transfer this thing I don't watch my
terminology without moving it or copying
it so you can't copy it but you can move
it the move the node handle mind you
know move happens to the element and you
just call insert with this thing and
you're done and of course if your code
is such that this all happens in a our
value context then you don't even have
to call move another example let's say I
want to merge these two sets well that's
one line of code just call merge notice
what happened here right it's a set not
a multiset there's two fives here so we
were merging source into destination
what when we're done we get destination
with all of source except that extra
five and that's left in source so no
element ever gets dropped on the floor
if you attempt to insert a node handle
and it doesn't work the insert returns
an extra parameter that is a node handle
of the thing that didn't get inserted so
it doesn't get dropped on the floor now
if you ignore it it'll get destructed by
the destructor of the node handle but
and by the way that'll happen using the
correct allocator
a copy of your allocator but nothing's
ever dropped on the floor unless you
want it to be you also can use this this
is a slightly more interesting example
here to make incredibly efficient
factories now sometimes I mean it's
great to be able to in place you know
things in place but sometimes a factory
is really a pattern that you want to use
so how do we make an efficient Factory
so this factory function takes a car
star and it it's gonna create a new a
new record in my map of int and string
right and it's gonna manage the ID for
me so that's that's why I want a factory
here okay so how do I do that well down
here I just call insert new record with
whatever and it just works so how does
that work there's a temporary map I'm
going to emplace the the thing into the
temporary map so that's fully efficient
constructs it once in the temporary map
I'm then going to extract that node and
return the node handle notice it says
auto here okay and that's now here is
going to be an R value so I can directly
insert it into my new table and all it
does is fiddle with the pointers the
thing in memory never moves
and I think that's it that's gonna be
questions discussion thoughts yeah so
the short the really short answer is I
don't know because I'm not concurrency
expert by any stretch of the imagination
so concurrency I took a slide out where
I was going to talk about this but
there's a lot of ways to get speed out
of with modern computers modern
programming probably the single most
important is is concurrency right we
have multiple processors we need to keep
them busy that's a whole topic on its
own it's I'm not the person to talk
about it and when you talk about
concurrent container containers I don't
know how those stack up this is how you
write individual threads and make them
fast so
one of the things that I didn't mention
earlier give me a minute I have to bring
it back
any other questions while I'm thinking
of what I was gonna say okay so his
comment was that moving shared pointers
can really improve your concurrency the
performance characteristics yeah so what
I was gonna say is that what the whole
point of this talk is to say that
writing efficient code isn't just for
people who work for you know National
Laboratories or that guy down the hall
who never opens his blinds and has a
editor that's green on black it's it's
for everybody all the time
you you know I like to always be
thinking about is the code I'm writing
optimal and efficient and when you do
that you end up we after you've written
a big program with a big program that
runs fast that and and is correct and
you don't have to worry about going back
and tuning it unless you run into one of
those situations where it's spending a
whole bunch of its time in one little
spot
Alistair's point is a very good one
efficient isn't just fast it's it's
energy efficient
I learned something oh this was some
years ago now that really surprised me
and there's people in the room who I'm
sure can talk about this all day but the
cost of a typical computer over its
lifetime is something like
at the time it was something like 25%
the equipment and 75% the power to run
it for its lifetime I mean the cost of
power is huge and if you don't need as
much computing power right if you don't
need as much memory and all these things
cost us money and and if you can if you
can run it for less time to get a
certain amount of work done that's
you're saving money other questions
thoughts comments suggestions I know
everyone's thinking beer and hot dogs
I'm sorry I
I can't accept I have been unable to get
invited to the slack Channel I've been
it's been blocked and not working but
I'm sure that the slides are going to be
made available because I and I and I'm
pretty sure that the video is gonna be
made available so you will it will be
available sure are you talking about new
record sure if I wanted it to take
something other than a char star right
oh oh you're saying in this actual code
okay so the question was should this be
a forward right okay so so so you're
saying change change the new record to
be able to take more than just a char
star and in which case we would want to
if we're gonna make it a template we'd
want to perfect forward what whatever
came in into the end place
that's correct I wrote this to show
something else so I wasn't really
worried about that but if we wanted this
to be you know more Universal we would
want to do that for sure yes you're
right that's a very good point the way
this is implemented this particular you
know which you'd never hopefully never
do like this or maybe that would be
exactly the the soso allister's point
was that as soon as you start making
more more of these because it's a
template every single one of them has
its own static in ID so its own ID
starting from zero and since they're all
going in the same place that's almost
certainly wrong so the question the
comment was that you would have to use
piecewise construct here in the in place
call if you use a very attic that's a
really interesting comment I don't know
the answer I would have thought not I
would hope not I hate that anyway a lot
but it wasn't the original design um but
it it may be the case and I don't know
the answer I don't know if anyone's
compiler and in their head can do that
that's right that's definitely true if
there's more than two things here you're
definitely going to have to use it yes
because you're not going to make this a
very attic right you're gonna make this
to take a single string template
parameter right yeah other questions
comments thoughts anyone I have a
question okay I'm sorry good yes okay I
like that very much thank you so the
comment was instead of saying optimize
everything or write everything
optimally the topic really should have
been don't pesum eyes at all anywhere I
agree I mean I think it's it's somewhat
a matter of semantics but it's a good
way to think about it right it's like if
it doesn't matter or if you know if
you're writing code where it just
doesn't matter
you know how the normal way to write it
can't be improved on which is lots of
code or you're in a situation where it
really genuinely doesn't matter and I'm
gonna say like user interfaces but then
I'm gonna remind you of my opening story
typing is a user interface phenomenon
right so it's not always true that user
interfaces it doesn't matter then just
right normal code but when you are in a
situation where it could matter or where
you're doing something where how you
write it matters be sure you're not Pesa
maizing at all yeah I agree
that's excellent
I had a question does anyone disagree
that that we need to think about these
things and that there's some sort of a
problem with a thousand times faster
computer not keeping up with typing that
a thousand times slower computer could
keep up with even given that it's doing
lots of other stuff I know there's a lot
of fluff in there but a thousand times
anyone disagree okay the comment was we
need OS driver developers in the room to
hear those things fair enough
there's a lot of factors absolutely but
I've certainly run into a lot of of the
kind of thinking I'll oh oh did someone
turn there we go thank you I've run into
a lot of attitude of the attitude that
it just doesn't matter I mean you know I
not to pick on Java but I'd love to pick
on Java in Java and and I'm not job
expert so tell me if I'm if I'm
incorrect but in Java you've got little
int and big in right and they're very
fundamentally different but all of your
user-defined types are like big and they
all are objects which means they're all
dynamically allocated so you can't embed
things in you can't embed one user
object in another directly and that just
has mungus space and time implications
and I was involved in a project some
years ago now where that was really they
tried to do a Big Data project in Java
and it failed miserably and that I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty convinced that
that kind of thing that was a lot of the
reason
different design patterns we used fly
weights a lot more in Java where you can
stock using object identity to avoid
having these plans and things yeah I
know the comment was used the design
patterns that work for the language
you're using which is certainly a a wise
thing to say but I think that in C++
using the correct design idioms you end
up with code that can't be improved on
particularly even if you were writing an
assembly code and that's the whole point
of C++ right so it is exactly 6 o'clock
any other questions comments thank you
[Applause]